taining yada yada yada what's up guys
hahaha Greg Alba Lauren Francesca an
awesome talented human being is sitting
next to me right now watch her Channel
I want my Lauren Amelie just stop
watching this one there's no need to
just go to hers the richest an awesome
Channel the most hilarious YouTube
comments of all time the richest that
you like top ten videos a lot of the
time
brilliant channel I think the lists are
amazing Lauren and I have experienced
YouTube comments in our days I tell you
I get the nastiest ones like take off
your clothes Greg just take off your
clothes people constantly demand it's
like all they want from me is this like
just like sexual aggression that people
feel towards me and I'm like guys I'm
I'm not like that okay I'm not just some
good-looking thing to be taken advantage
of Lauren has no idea what that's like
though no horns complete opposite side
of the spectrum yeah look at me
glad you're here Lauren let's watch this
video okay
hello YouTube is a fantastic site to be
entertained or just waste time while you
run down the clock at work that's what I
do maybe what drawing people to the site
the comments section can also prove to
be a real attraction yes arguments the
youtube comment section can also
generate some pretty funny responses
hilarious user comments these better be
funny here clip dr. strengthen a hip
abductors rights in Psy's video sleeve
very popular and more than a few people
head over to YouTube you can help an
information about work yeah
a video entitled hip abductors
strengthening was meant for physical
therapy use but became famous for more
juvenile yet funny observation no yep
prompted by the awkward looking clothes
of the instructor one user posted that
that's exactly how I look after I take
it dump then realize there's no toilet
paper and have to get up and go find
something sure it's crude but it's no
fun okay like done an exercise video
clips on YouTube would teach various
self-defense video intitled techniques
of how to punch and strike fast method
one does what you'd expect as an
individual shows it moves answer typical
dummy cockle Scout 74 became an instant
comedian when he posted what if my
opponent has arms what do i do then the
sarcasm blaze comment received thousands
of likes and probably left more than one
person wondering John's hilarious who
hasn't headed on over to YouTube to
watch their favorite artists perform a
song or two John Legend is an example of
one popular singer who attracts a lot of
attention good boy sometimes people can
get a bit carried away and post things
before they think not maybe they're
having clearly listened to legend posted
I wish I could steal John Legend's voice
and put it in a box and just listen to
it every day the overly dramatic post
was made to not only look cooler
I became comedy gold
gun demonstration as seen in a video
titled tourists raging judge
demonstration one of the favorite video
supposed involves firearms and the
shooting of target okay the video use
six watermelons I've done that one user
let people in stitches when they
commented that this video is fake or
rigged I've been hunting watermelon in
the wild
I like that one funny cute and funny but
totally accepted by a post in the
comment section out of nowhere
several years ago user David ate raw
posted I have an actual real house cat
after I take a bomb yet I swear I can
type in English about sixty second young
the comment made a lot of people's
comments across the web
Wow brilliant Neil Patrick Harris Neil
Patrick Harris can act you can sing he
produces he does comedy is often called
upon to host award shows he seems like
an all-around awesome
Betty is video hosting the 2012 Tony
Award starting getting a lot of negative
comments believe with the actors
homosexuality one user to use it all of
it in the funny comment that why made in
gay because it is straight no other man
would have a chance that's true that's
true there's a lot of informative videos
on YouTube as one user who knows
pending on when is what you're watching
YouTube can be quite an indicator to
your lifestyle video entitled what is
your voice to others showing it's a
Friday night analyzed criticized and
parodies - the wrecking ball video has
some interesting images which means
happen - he wrote specifically ok
well thank you the richest one of those
was definitely hilarious yeah your
favorite the one about the watermelons
brilliantly thought-out you know he used
sarcasm but are you really committed to
it
made a picture for us put himself in the
situation I'm actually hunting for
watermelons he took time to go out of
his way honestly a lot of the other
choices though I felt were you know
predictable richest I got to say I think
your sense of humor may be a little off
yeah I don't know I just look at
comments and I just get scared I don't
like feeling of comments that scares me
what comments are an interesting thing I
don't read the comments as much as
people would probably like me to every
once in a while I upload a video
depending on what kind of video it is I
like to see what some of the comments
saying and sometimes I'll take time to
reply back to some loving comments
because I know people sometimes like
having a reply or two I decided not to
read the comments for a while because
for several I was just telling you this
actually I'm gonna tell it to you again
cuz I'm selling it to you now buddy the
bigger I get the bigger you get the more
hey you're gonna get two no matter how
much I build up my self my rhinoceros
skin and okay we'll get to my brain
three I didn't even like the fact that
when I was getting loving comments that
that was the thing that I would go to to
make me feel better I didn't like having
to get validation off of anyone else's
opinion and so I have to take time to
step away from it yeah haters I'll just
block you a block haters you get a lot
of eaters yeah really yeah if you have
to say something to all your haters
right now what would you say I know what
I was saying if somebody says something
mean to me like I don't say mean things
to people that pulls me help people like
say mean things
don't say anything mean to people like
if you don't like something just don't
watch it I would say forgive them Lord
for they know not what they do
Jesus Christ the Bible thank you that
was probably my favorite one the one
where it's like
taking a dump the hip adductors yeah
well that's how I feel like if I do any
exercise videos I'm like ooh who does
this look like I'm taking it dump right
now actually for what exercise this
woman have to do yeah I'm gonna have to
do a lot of squatting
I feel like self-conscious I see some
woman at like LA Fitness and dude some
of the craziest workouts yeah you know
where they put like the the barbell
under they're not torso and they like to
do the lip they lift up with her hips do
you do that ever no that's just so
insane that's so insane there's like
machines they built so it's not as
complicated for you to do that anymore
the joke about the dummy not having arms
I've heard that joke so many times I
grew up in the martial arts world
Taekwondo I got a black belt when I was
10 years old Wow fact about me gonna put
that on my in the book soon I tell you
like I killed the crowds at the classes
every time when I was hitting like what
do I do if there's no arms and then all
the yellow belts the kids the Hispanic
kids will just start cracking up so yeah
I invented that joke I don't care we go
Scout 94 go to hell I wish I could steal
John Legend's voice to put it in a box
and just listen to it every day why
would you consider that hilarious yeah
why do you not know funny
we know funny we know fun watch I'll
make you laugh right now I got a classic
joke and my father told me Lauren how
did Captain Hook die I don't know he
wiped his ass with the wrong hand I know
my dad was a brilliant man Steven Alba
Thanks
this is not funny Neil Patrick Harris
when I totally agree I was watching the
last episode I showed John the last two
episodes of How I Met Your Mother
recently have you seen that show yeah
not the last two episodes it's the worst
ending ever really oh I've been telling
that to John since the show ended and
then I just show it to John last week if
he was appalled by how that show and
Neil Patrick Harris though he plays you
know like but go get her for like yeah
he's a total woman I was so [ __ ]
ridiculous in the show who Barney is at
the same time he does exude this aura of
innocence in confidence from like I
could totally see woman sleeping with
this guy left and right yeah he's hot he
is hot
gosh he's perfect if I was gay maybe I
don't even need to be gay it would just
be a cool thing to tell people that I
did yeah that I slept with Neil Patrick
Harris I'd love to see that can you
tweet to Neil Patrick Harris that if he
ever offers Greg is willing to go I
could have made a lot of puns that are
but I didn't like the baseball cap one
richest literally observation comedy
come on it's like was hot yes you
pointed out that oh I wish I had the
base oh that's funny
byah I guess in some way but he could
have been more clever like we'll make it
clever ready you're about to watch two
brilliant
comedic artists okay come up with a more
brilliant comment about what this idiot
did all right Loren let's do this video
games maybe
I don't know yeah I got nothing I
thought yeah I guess he did have the
best common Wow my you guys been up this
whole time maybe other people are
allowed to be funny yeah you know I
learned a valuable lesson today Thank
You Lauren well I'm gonna valuable
lesson I have been humbled I am not the
only funny person out there really well
John makes jokes all the time but I
rarely do I break a laugh
you need ten jokes since you've been
here I think I've laughed at a few times
like pure mockery this has been a fun
video for everyone included yeah if
you're new to the channel subscribe to
the revealer rejects Lauren Francesca
has a channel sketch channel yeah Lauren
put stuff up there that show her awesome
personality and one with her creative
intuition thank you thank you I hope
you're not being sarcastic I mean I am
sarcasm isn't even a word in my
dictionary uh-huh I don't know such a
thing okay yeah whose sarcastic god yes
yes God is very sarcastic
every day God is testing me some people
say you're creating your own problems
and then I'm like no it's just God
Testament little life lesson for you
guys and Lauren's also on Instagram
Twitter Facebook snapchat vine other
[ __ ] musically live me Tumblr Pinterest
that's it she is just out there no time
to herself no time to herself all the
make you laugh I love all the entertain
you guys I love you thank you for
watching yeah it's the love I did it to
her give me some love give me some love
right now like on my channel
if you would subscribe to it I'd be
really appreciative and I come over here
more because then I'd be like Oh grace
rejects came to me oh because oh yeah
that makes sense if you guys subscribe
to her Channel it'll entice her to be
like oh there's benefits to come in on
the real rejects cuz you look for ideal
it for like 40 minutes away
that's far telling it's far just think
about yeah the fact that a human being
can travel 65 miles per hour or more and
we consider that far how lazy us humans
have become yes that's comedy Free
People